hey what's up guys marcus brownlee here
from mkbhd and today we have another
freeware tutorial for you guys and this
one is going to be about compressing
videos
compressing any video format to be much
much smaller file size
you might have noticed that if you're
not a youtube partner you have a maximum
video upload length to youtube of 10
minutes and a maximum file size of one
gig and recently i had a video an
unboxing uh video actually that went up
to 1.37 gigs when i produced it in 1280
by 720 hd
um so yeah we had a little problem we
had to uh i was looking around for ways
to actually upload this video and i
found a compressor so now i'm going to
show it to you guys this one is uh it's
available at the link in the description
dvdvideosoft.com
and a number of things after that url
but you can see there's basically a free
studio of different software utilities
and they're all freeware
and if we scroll down here we'll see
there's um not only youtube downloaders
and uploaders but the one we're gonna uh
we're interested in here is free video
to flash converter
4.1.3 and this is actually the latest
version at the time that i'm making the
video but go ahead and get the latest
version uh so we're just going to do is
click on it and it'll take us to a
download link and you're going to hit
that download button
only 10.6 megabytes and now i'm going to
show you guys uh once you've downloaded
and installed it which is fairly simple
uh how to uh how to actually uh compress
the video
so here we go we're going to open up
this piece of software here i have it in
a shortcut we're going to double click
it and it actually opens up the studio
menu now i didn't download all 20 pieces
of uh freeware i only downloaded the
youtube to mp3 converter and the free
video to flash converter which is what
we're going to use so go ahead and click
on the video to flash converter and
it'll open up
and here's the the interface of it uh so
it's very simple interface we have the
input files the output folder and the
formats uh so
i'm just going to browse for a file that
we want to upload or even if it's not
one gigabyte we're going to look for a
file that's really big that would take a
long time to upload we want to just
shorten that time that upload time so
here we go we'll find a file here
this uh this matthias unboxing uh which
actually i have not uploaded yet is
0.98 gigs
so it's really really close to one
gigabyte and i don't want to be uh
running that risk so i'm just going to
open up that file uh this video file
it's a mov file and yes this does work
for mov mp4 etc
and what we're going to do is choose our
output folder and i'm going to save it
to the desktop in the mkbhd folder hit
ok
and we're going to use the flv format uh
the flv format will upload to youtube
and will be actually processed must much
faster because that's what youtube
uses youtube processes videos to turn
them all into flv format so if you're
uploading an flv video uh it won't take
quite as long to process and then when
we go to uh presets we're gonna go all
the way down to the uh highest ultra
high lan
uh wi-fi uh bandwidth so um you can go
either very high or ultra high if your
videos are really really high like 30 40
gigs you can go from high to hot to very
high bandwidth so i'm going to choose
ultra high here and go to edit
and since we want to preserve this uh
this hd
hd uploading to youtube we're going to
change the dimensions to 1280x720
and we're also going to change the frame
rate to our highest 30 frames per second
for smooth uh smooth video so we have
stereo audio uh pretty much pretty much
the highest bit rate you need 1280 by
720 we're going to hit ok
and this is where the magic happens you
know the video is beginning to process
or not to process but to actually be
compressed and converted
into uh this flash format all we got to
do is hit this convert button convert
so here it goes the file conversion um
obviously isn't the fastest in the world
since it is a pretty large file but i'll
come back to you guys um after the
conversion is done and we're just going
to speed it up here by going to high
priority so here we go
all right guys we're back and it says
the process is complete and the
conversion was completed successfully
okay so what this means is that uh the
the flv file is now in the uh the output
folder which we've chosen which is on
our desktop in that folder so let's exit
out of uh exit out of the converter here
and go to that exact folder
and here it is we see a whole lot of
files and most of these are not
necessary so i'm going to delete them
the only one you want to keep is the flv
file
so i'm just going to erase the rest of
these
and we're going to keep this flv file so
here's the original.mov file you can see
down at the bottom here this is 0.98
gigabytes just about up to the limit for
the largest file size you can upload to
youtube now let's click on the flv file
and look down here
68.7 megabytes and it's still hd quality
video will be uploaded to youtube in a
matter of seconds and it's all about a
matter of putting in the description
fast enough before the video is uploaded
so yeah if you do have a video or two
that are just way too big for youtube
and you need to compress them down to a
more realistic file size then i do
recommend this piece of freeware again
available at the link in the description
if you want to go check it out anyway
this has been marcus brownlee from mkbhd
i hope you like this tutorial if you do
have any other tutorial ideas or
requests go ahead and subscribe and
message me through youtube i read all my
emails and i might even do a request
video for you i do do request videos
again thanks for watching this video and
i hope it was helpful peace